diane you play a true ice cream in the
series um did you take inspiration from
anyone that you met as a young model or
a young actress starting out in your
career i mean a lot of it was on the
page you know i mean i'm just repeating
words i think i um if anything based on
male
characters that i've met along my career
and that i've been able to observe
um and also what i would think to me
would be the most
scary part you know if i had to work for
somebody what i what i would be
the most afraid of i tried to put into
um
and i i just love that the character
also allowed me to show her
you know her side at home her vulnerable
side the struggles that she's going
through so
it made for you know the more outrageous
i was at work the more the home stuff i
guess you know paid off
karen it must have been amazing to get
to work with an icon like diane and what
what lessons did you learn from her
during the project um i mean i love
watching other actors work and
this was such an amazing role for you
and i just
kind of i feel like the the job of my or
part of my character was watching you so
it was like very easy to
to take you in and and take all the
thoughtfulness that you brought to the
role in because most of my character was
also you know just admiring you so it
was it was it was nice that i got to do
that and then also that it felt like i
was actually like that was part of my
job um but it was amazing i mean i i
think you're just like such a um
you you portray things with like such a
delicate hand and it's it's amazing to
to watch so it was a real it was a real
treat and then also you know besides
watching
actually doing scenes where we were kind
of connected to one another yeah really
natural and really right and you know
diane's a boss she's a pro so it was
just it was just really fun
um
diane joyce is a very powerful woman who
struggles with society's expectations of
having it all and is that something that
you've dealt with personally as like
obviously a hollywood superstar who's
also a mom
yeah that's what i meant earlier when i
said like those were you know the mo the
more challenging role i mean aspect of
that character because obviously that's
been very true in my life right i pushed
back
um
on family and and
putting a real importance on that for a
long time and so
most of my girlfriends did the same
right so i feel like it's a very
relatable
2022 um
female i don't want to say problem it's
just it is what it is but it's
definitely something that's on
on our minds and that most women go
through these days
worth yeah and just one question for
karen have you ever had any truly
horrible bosses
no no luckily i i have not had any
horrible bosses i uh i feel
like i've um
i've had a very lucky run i've had a
very very very good run
lucky you i wish i could stay the same
no i i want that for everyone